[Musique]
il y avait quelque chose d'étrange cet
endroit là les plus vives en parlait
beaucoup je l'a entendu 1-2 dire si vous
allez au verger ce soir faites attention
parce que y'a un tout d'abord un trou
excuse elle est planté un autre beau me
suis alors mis
au pensionnat de kamloops on l'appelait
le verger du frère joseph
autant qu'il parlait du verger à
belgrade où on voulait aller y voler des
pommes et nuit un des gars m'a dit je ne
devrais pas celle acquise intérêts
marque pas
pendant des décennies c'était un endroit
entouré de mystère et de parts
aujourd'hui on soupçonne une scène de
crime
nous avons localisé deux sensible qui
ressemblent à des sépultures
depuis la découverte de ce qui semble
être des tombes anonymes à kamloops des
indices laissent croire qu'il y en
aurait des centaines d'autres au pays le
canada a entrepris son examen de
conscience mais des voix s'élèvent pour
que la société québécoise admettent
aussi sa part de responsabilité
il faut comprendre comment elle a
participé au pensionnat comment elle a
participé à la conquête de l'ouest et ça
le québec est pas ou étranger à ça
ça
à une époque c'était le plus grand
pensionnats pour autochtones au pays des
milliers d'enfants arrachés à leurs
familles et aussi journée
[Musique]
marche ici c'est moi puis mon frère gary
et plus pluvieux steve
vous voyez en sourit tous si vous
regardez dans les yeux on a l'air
heureux
passionnant
j'ai su que ça ne serait pas un clown
endroit dès que j'ai mis les pieds
[Musique]
le plus les prêtres et les religieuses
sont arrivés mes frères sont parties
d'un côté mes soeurs de l'autre je ne
les ai jamais revus on se parle
entre les murs de kamloops la mort
frappe est souvent
[Musique]
e
la grippe et la tuberculose ils ont été
plus meurtrières que dans la population
générale et puis il y a eu les autres
décès
après la messe on avait l'habitude
d'aller se promener on partait de
l'école
[Musique]
ont le sens des verts lagrange le long
de la rivière
est là en passant près de la grange on a
vu quatre jeunes garçons et la bande
il ne touchait pas le seul il était
pendu
audrey a posé des questions au sujet des
garçons elle a été punie
je questionnais sans cesse et on a puni
à cause de ça pour que j'apprenne un
tacle
il n'était pas rare que des enfants
disparaissent à ce jour la commission de
vérité et réconciliation a identifié
plus de 4000 enfants morts dans les
pensionnats mais son président estime
que le chiffre pourrait dépasser 20
milles
à kamloops 51 enfants sont décédés
officiellement mais ceux qui rendent cet
endroit ce sont les autres les disparus
dont les noms n'apparaissent pas au
registre
choses étranges surviennent et échappe
c'est seulement en vieillissant octobre
la grc n'a pas fait dans kate
pourquoi il n'y a pas eu ce corner de
coin
au fil du temps car il faisait des
questions mexico
[Musique]
norman avait 8 ans quand son meilleur
ami a disparu un enfant qui dormaient
dans le même dortoir une victime
d'agression sexuelle croit nos mines
comme lui même l'a été et où l on
pourrait dire que c'était un simple
d'esprit en élite un jour il a disparu
oui nous partager une armoire et du jour
au lendemain sa brosse à nac son
dentifrice qui sont peigne n'était plus
là a dit wang j'ai posé demande hills
qui lui est arrivé
il savait je ne peux que supposer que
pourrait être leur sol en terre et dans
l'énergie
[Musique]
en l'absence de preuves matérielles
n'a pu que spéculer pendant des années
le chef lebourdais se souvient des
récits de son oncle et cette dame m'a
raconté que lorsqu'il était au début de
l'adolescence
il arrivait qu'un prêtre ou un frère
s'approche des jeunes garçons
et ils ont choisi ces quatre faux
nez aux en obligé de se battre puis
après les deux auri avec une fricadelle
prenez les gagnants et les faisait se
battre entre eux
ensuite ils ont mené le gagnant ou de
perdant avec eux une fois c'est arrivé à
mon oncle
ils lui ont fait creuser un trou
dans le verger
les garçons ont fini par comprendre
qu'ils étaient tombés
dès l'aurore san mamès creuse un trou
quelqu'un disparaît qui creuse un trou
que disparaît
j'ai un défi l'agresser sexuellement
sont tombées enceintes
qu'est-il arrivé à ces baby
[Musique]
pendant longtemps la réponse à cette
question n'a été que des murmures
aujourd'hui on ose le dire à haute voix
un homme m'a demandé si j'étais déjà
allé dans la salle du bourg mais
quand je suis allé une fois et je n'ai
jamais voulu y retourner
se met à pleurer il m'a dit que c'était
un endroit horrible
il a dit qu'il a décidé d'aider la
donne et on ne savait pas ce qu'elle
contenait ce que nous promet un bébé on
est tombé
[Musique]
serrés ces deux nourrissons envoyé à
l'incinérateur existe dans plusieurs
communautés autochtones du pays ils sont
difficiles à concevoir mais pas pour les
survivants des pensionnats
quand on a vécu des choses comme ça
point de vue des enfants disparaît quand
même
c'est pas si difficile à croire
l'an dernier la nation tu es kamloops dc
cointe a voulu savoir si la science
pouvait confirmer ce que dit la
tradition orale depuis des générations
[Musique]
on cherche ce sont surtout des fausses
on ne veut pas voir d'ossements ou de
corps
krugman
[Musique]
l'archéologue sarah beaulieu et
spécialiste en géoradar son équipe a été
embauché pour explorer le site en
commençant par le verger
[Musique]
créé une anomalie dans le seul canton
creusent une tombe et qu'on replace en
suit la terre sa cause une perturbation
et c'est ce que nous cherchons à
identifier
this toujours su depuis que je suis
toute petite qu'il y avait des enfants
enterrés
dit un autre jour est une survivante de
kamloops est l'instigatrice des fouilles
pour moi ces enfants existent ne sont
pas les miens je vais
elle est aidée par ted gottfredson un
membre de la communauté
hippie de l'islande et à peut-être qu'on
trouvera j'espérais qu'on trouvera ainsi
mais je ne voulais pas assisté aux
fouilles
avec émotionnellement ce serait trop
difficile pour moi car myself
médias ne tenait qu'à y être pour
apporter réconfort aux âmes des petits
disparus à cet os je leur dis n'ayez pas
peur il vous chers et
ils vont confirmer ce que notre
tradition orale ou dix ans et que j'ai
toujours su
on est ici pour vous trouver enfin
personne n'était préparé à l'ampleur de
la découverte
[Musique]
2 à quake sattouf rap seulement quand il
voit les résultats dans le récent du
racing
le monde je pense que c'est arrivé quand
on a fait un dernier tour du site avant
mon départ
avec les membres de la communauté
le silence
s'est instruit le silence en disait long
inde airways ana c'est là que tu te
rends compte y est restée saisissent
affreux avant
[Musique]
dès mardi
sinama appelé le dimanche et manon ce
qu'il est avec 215 sépulture
je n'arrivais pas à y croire je
n'arrêtais pas de répéter tu as bien des
215 wii 2 5 jan
[Musique]
la découverte a déclenché un déferlement
d'émotion et de soutien des canadiens
que les découvertes troublantes à
kamloops en colombie britannique
les restes de 215 enfants ont été
retrouvés dans une fosse commune elle a
attiré l'attention du monde entier
la réaction en est-il de tristesse et de
stupeur partagé par la classe politique
à tous ceux qui souffrent je suis
vraiment désolé que votre pays vous a
laissé tomber le premier ministre ait eu
l'air de tomber de la lune quand il ya
eu ces découvertes là alors que en fait
il était premier ministre quand le
rapport de la commission de vérité
réconciliation même si c'est pas lui qui
l'avait demandé a été remis quand même
un volume iv qui est spécifiquement
sur le sujet alors ça prouve que
personne n'avait lu ce fameux rapport
ce n'était pourtant pas la première fois
qu'on repérer la présence de sépulture
anonyme autour d'anciens pensionnat
dès les années 70 on en a trouvé 72a
battleford en saskatchewan
ensuite cent soixante et une fort
providence dans les territoires du
nord-ouest depuis 2012 les découvertes
de trois autres sites dans les prairies
sont passé largement inaperçu du grand
public
même la découverte la plus marquante à
dolbeau en alberta est passé sous le
radar
à la fin des années 90 ainsi au et
glissements de terrain et
il ya des ossements humains qui se sont
retrouvés dans la rivière qui jouxte le
terrain et le on ne réalisait qu'il
s'agissait de sépultures en 1m liés aux
pensionnaires
le pensionnat de dolbeau et un des trois
premiers pensionnaires qui tape les
écoles industrielle au moment de au
moment où il a été créé en 1883
nous sommes au tout début du système
canadien des pensionnats les premiers
établissements sont construits dans
l'ouest du pays
du canada
beaucoup de gens l'ignorent mais de
nombreux religieux et religieuses qui
ont oeuvré dans les pensionnats de
l'ouest étaient canadiens français et
albert l'aco qui est un missionnaire
canadien français très très connu à
l'époque très influent surtout qui a
suggéré aussi de bâtir ces écoles
résidentielles avec beaucoup d'échecs en
fait au départ et chic parce que les
enfants ne veulent pas rester au
pensionnat c'est pour ça aussi que le
système va se durcir ça va devenir
obligatoire
un avion vient chercher les petits
indiens pour les amener dans un
pensionnat bissati
chaque réserve au lendemain d'une
bénédiction des canaux sans presse au
bord de la mer pour asus pire au départ
de ses enfants il près de l'école
séculaire de la transhumance
le gouvernement va devoir prendre des
grands moyens moyens violents pour être
capable d'enrouler ces enfants là dans
les écoles
on glane le gouvernement fédéral et les
églises catholique et protestante qui
ont contraint les enfants autochtones à
l'assimilation mais le québec aurait
tort de s'en dédouaner il a fait partie
du projet dès sa mise en place
le québec est une des quatre premières
provinces occupe une grande partie de la
chambre des communes du parlement
calendes est donc de racheter s'assure
un fédéral qui sera extérieure à nous ça
me semble déjà problématique
cette mission-là a été connue au québec
c'était dans les journaux ce fait les
gens donnaient de l'argent pour financer
ces entreprises là en tout état de cause
c'est à dire avec une rhétorique était
très raciste qui est inférieur et êtes
complètement les premières nations et
qui visait à les remblais
[Musique]
notre société est issu donc de la
société qui a bâti ces pensionnats là
qui les a supporté qui était d'accord
avec cette mission on a certainement une
responsabilité partagée avec l'ensemble
de la société coloniale canadien blanche
donc la responsabilité elle est là le
choc de kamloops a fait re surgir de
douloureux souvenirs aux milliers
d'enfants qui ont fréquenté les
pensionnats et foyers du québec
ici aussi on songe à entreprendre des
fouilles pour déterrer la vérité il faut
absolument impérativement qu'on sache
exactement ce qui s'est passé le mieux
possible j'entends beaucoup parler de
réconciliation là mais à mon avis on en
est loin là n'en est pas là du tout on
va apprendre à faire la paix avec cette
histoire là qu est une histoire avec
laquelle c'est très difficile d'être en
paix parce que c'étaient des enfants
[Musique]
65 ans entre le moment où j'étais agacé
seul et où ils ont trouvé les sépultures
effectué
[Musique]
à nous je n'ai jamais plus bien respirer
ça m'aurait permis de raconter mon
histoire eu
[Musique]
il ya plein d'émotions qui longtemps
dahir l'espace de quelques secousses a
connu beaucoup de colère
et puis des larmes puis-je
sait
je les ai toujours su
faire les enfants des territoires
[Musique]
peu tout le monde
non e
[Musique]